yeah minutes away from going live
mighty were you ready to know what we
need to do right before we go on stage
right in the group not good or state
come on just do it go girl Spice Girls
yeah go [ __ ] it we're not go to the
stage that we're cooking here this team
right now is the time to show off
remember yes in the practice you were
brilliant what we're gonna do is Sunna
carpaccio with brandy flamed prawns and
then a reduction about some vinegar and
truffle well I'm gonna teach you today
is exactly what I need to do tomorrow so
it's pan-seared scallop yeah sat on a
cauliflower puree finished with caper
raisin and truffle okay okay open them
knife in twist up sales and pull it back
look how thin I'm gonna slice this
slightly overlap them garlic
shaped this is sizzling put the prawns
in there pinch of chilli flakes so 1
minutes on each side little touch of
salt butter put a little bit brand in
there then I get a blowtorch step back
back back tip upside down now when's
your birthday you're very artistic
aren't you no time to cook the scallops
Pam nice and hot just need a little
smidgen of oil we start off at 12
o'clock a little bit of truffle oil
before we finish I want to see drops got
a nice thin slice of ciabatta bread
gonna we're not.we on take a razor
vinaigrette
Jerry Jesus Christ this is our full of
on spicy and what we're gonna do from
there is just take the top which we call
the mousse and just put a touch of that
sort of mousse and there we are
why do you think of your ideas
Bette and there we are what happens to
me Jerry chill let me teach you why I
want from you if I can get some gaffer
tape over her mouth and just get it to
cook we may make this this isn't working
Martin you put in too much pressure well
it'll be thick that see Jerry's just
[ __ ] that one how'd you manage that
Jerry Jean oh yes Jerry
no we're fine why [ __ ] show you why
Gordon a now we have a completely
different style or run in the kitchen
his style is to pull fear into people
Jerry come on the difference between
fear and love
believe you me history tells us the
loves always win
that's a puree Jerry as a puree you
can't be this [ __ ] bad seriously the
last time I was this proud is when I saw
my son walking we done Gordon if there
is any help you need from us you just
let us know we'll be very happy to help
you out the problem we going to a head
that we're gonna eternally have to wait
for Gordon and it's table Jerry give me
rest give me an A hey Jimmy now he'll
give me a tea Hey what we got so use it
how
at tonight's banquet the starters are
minutes away from being served to our
special guests how's it going pretty
well
yeah astok knew our surgeon right yes so
you paraded on water to people a lot of
different teams several theaters nothing
can prepare you for something I don't
yes you just you just go into work mode
really and just focus on what's in front
of you and get on there sort of enormity
of it later is a really amazing well
done thank you training is one thing the
pressure of service is quite another
keep an eye we [ __ ] up the bread I don't
have any more bread you need to prepare
it before yes sir this you prepare
before you start to cook
no cooking and now what is the [ __ ]
utensils jeez you're bigger problems I
have it all suddenly stream about find
they're not this thing we trained hard
so you know train hard race season in
the kitchen right now being told off for
every move we make it's mine it's mine
I hate little chefs it would be good
they're very nervous but I know that
they're gonna make it no problem there
let's go wait wait it's not 15 yet keep
them straight you've gone three minutes
only without seen anything training out
Gino concentrate Table four if you don't
take them I'll take them forward and we
are actually on time I got out the gate
early to get in front of Gino for two
minutes so it's a bit of a chef's thing
bit naughty but that's the kind of games
I play when I want to win